well Adrian Brown has been reporting on
China and Hong Kong for 30 years and
joins us now Adrian you covered the
handover in 1997 people are excited
about the prospect but today in Hong
Kong Chinese flags are being desecrated
where did it all go wrong you're
absolutely right on July the 1st 1997 I
remember standing in the street watching
people cheer waving red flags as Chinese
troops arrived in Hong Kong there was
real excitement that Hong Kong was now
part of the motherland that Hong Kong
was going to have a really bright future
because it had been promised so much it
was going to be this exclusive region of
China and there was real optimism that
the one country two systems' formula
agreed between Britain and China was
going to work but then after about six
years
come 2003 things started to go wrong
that was when the local government sided
to push through a Sedition bill that
brought half a million people onto the
streets a few years later the government
tried to put through a new education
bill that would promote patriotic
education and then fast forward to 2014
and we have the National People's
Congress in Beijing China's Parliament
ruling that yes Hong Kong can have
universal suffrage but China would vet
the candidates that of course brought
thousands of people onto the streets for
the Occupy movement and these in many
way the people you see on the streets a
day the students are the are the same
people that were there in occupy in 2014
but came to the conclusion that actually
peaceful protest doesn't work so they
have revert they have decided to resort
to more violent means and you know what
we're seeing is much more intense
violence with no sign of that violence
ending so yes you know we have come from
a period when there was great excitement
about being part of the motherland - a
period now where many people in Hong
Kong are rejecting that and if there
would you say this is an inherent
tension within this one China tea system
so was it always doomed
a failure I think you know we can
establish now I think that you know I
remember thinking at the time in 1997
I'll be really surprised if this work
says so much that can go wrong we were
taking China at its word and you know
China at the end of the day was a
communist country it remains a communist
country but was being expected to
tolerate this sort of thing on its
doorstep democracy it was always going
to be a tough call and I think the
strains of that have now become very
very apparent and so you know a big
question mark remains can one country
two systems work I think you know that
is all going to become clear really in
the days and weeks ahead you know we are
in for you know what is going to be a
very very tense period after October the
first I think it's what happens after
October the first that's going to be
very telling because everything in the
last few days and weeks has been
building up to this moment and here we
are in Causeway Bay where the protesters
that were behind Sarah not long ago are
now making their way towards Causeway
Bay on the eastern side of Hong Kong
Island now today we have seen you know
plenty of violence we have had you know
live rounds used once more so the
violence is becoming much more intense a
much more sporadic much more widespread
okay Adrian Brown things do seem to be
heating up behind you we'll let you get
back to it there in Hong Kong but thanks
very much for bringing us some context
to this unfolding situation